[Music]
huh hey merch I know that we're not a
big conspiracy nut but this story really
has me [__] up time is running out a
controversial cell phone tower could be
activated as early as this what you're
looking behind that is that a school is
an elementary
school that's not a prison merch where
You' be like [__]
right Elementary School yeah it's like
yeah had a prison you'd go yeah [__]
it holy [__] oh [__] a controversial
cell phone tower could be activated as
early as this weekend at least you'll
get really good reception if there's a
shooting or there's an emergency if the
kids on top of a y and do school for
months parents have been fighting to
legally block the T-Mobile 5G Tower at
and it's T-Mobile out of everything-
mobile too Washington Elementary at one
point even proposed imagine getting some
weird brain cancer because you were next
to with T-Mobile tower bro imagine
building this Tower and like nobody at
the company was like hey I have a
question like you think this is going to
make bad press for us forget about
whether or not it's safe or not but it's
literally on the
schooling an alternate location all
without success but School
administrators and parents have been
vowing to keep pushing back until they
truly are out of option
are they there Shan I go to T-Mobile
Elementary School it's pretty cool joins
us now to explain what we all some of us
have powers some of us has leukemia real
50/50 shot
here happens children today we're going
to learn long divisions brought to you
by
T-Mobile everybody in that [__] V in
that town looks like The
Oblongs bro look at the tower looming
over the school behind
him and this guy kind of looks like a
villain this is great I love this yeah
he kind of looks like the dude from uh
the Watchman yeah goes aamus oh no he
actually looks like what's his face
homelander oh there you go tomorrow Sean
yes thank you Sean I'm standing on the
other side of the school which is about
as close as I'm willing to
get it's when you look at the other
picture hold on let me just got to show
you something that I caught when you
look at the other picture hold on it's
literally in the playground oh my God
it's in the playground God the [__]
5G Towers in the playground it's humming
like the tower at the end of
Westworld Devon let's show everyone what
we're talking about Washington
Elementary I can hear the hum of the
Tower and my
sleep that right behind me right on top
and this is where the parents and even
the superintendent says doesn't belong
here it's right on top of the school
looks like the end goal of a Devil May
Cry game it's really manad it looks like
you allow you how you how you lock a
section of the map in Far Cry found it
all day long it's over the playground as
well T-Mobile now poised to fire this
thing up it's been up there but has not
been turned on but Saturday is the day
they flipped the switch we spoke to the
superintendent who says he is trying to
work with this company to find a
solution but why did it happen to begin
with yeah like why are you just now
calling them didn't you ask what what
they were building I think maybe the
previous admin I don't know does can can
I get some more info on this this has
been a priority yes from July 1st yep
from the beginning James Anderson is the
new superintendent okay yeah like you
said and so it was the old it was the
old admin the old super the old
superintendent left with a nice Bag of
Money Y is working to find a solution to
the controversial T-Mobile cell tower
that is on top of Washington Elementary
the cell company and the school signing
a contract for the tower to go up here
years ago the deal costing former
superintendent Dr
C the deal cost her her job mhm yeah
well [__] it was paid for you know
[__] you know she didn't [__] she
ain't missing the job after that one oh
this is Wayne County oh yeah it's
Detroit okay yeah parents protested they
did not feel in the loop wow look at all
these conspiracy theory parents they
must all be conspiracy theorists yeah
because here's the thing about these
people that laugh at all this stuff it's
like oh you know there's a lot of wacky
[__] conspiracies that are clearly
stupid right obviously but there's also
this thing where these are the same
people that probably triple boosted
their kids made them all wear masks and
do all that stuff but even still no
matter how [__] they trust the
science no matter how many articles say
these towers are perfectly safe they're
like I'm not going to risk it though
yeah so no no I'm not risking it it's
just something ominous about it in the
cell tower deal making and they have
also it's like I'm not even against you
rolling out 5G but there's other places
you can put it mhm the
prison their I just can't wait till they
flip the switch in like two weeks this
school is just covered in dead
birds all the credit cards all the
credit cards are
demagnetized just piles of dead birds
all over the [__] ground the fourth
graders are walking around in circles
with nose bleeds and all the fifth
graders can taste as purple now it's
great to be exposed and the 5G still
sucks yes and it's still only three bars
at the school they still don't get
reception cuz the [__] all the lead
paint yeah power radiation all day it's
okay the Asbestos and Le Pain Shields
him from the 5G radiation so it's
fine every day at school parents said
they may have to leave the school
district and many have we've lost
students um we've lost approximately 75
students so far 75 students are gone
yeah they died of cancer yeah they
haven't turned it on yet I'll have you
know know that's the the concern of the
parents um that's my concern I think
that um I don't think it belongs here I
think that we need to move it um I have
made a proposal to uh T-mobile for for
an opportunity to Yo now that this got
enough coverage T-Mobile's going to have
to do something about it mhm because
this is bad PR really bad again though
this is like if you're working this deal
out right and I'm hip to it I would be
like hey can we rethink this plan I'm
just thinking long term and you know all
it's going to take is just one local
news reporter with a [__] Wild te up
his ass and we're going to have
everybody on us over this it just sounds
bad on paper remember that element
Elementary School when a bunch of
different people were getting cancer
because of radiation was underneath it
and they said it was safe the one in New
Jersey we covered on the show there was
radiation underneath the school for
years when they went there and I said no
it's fine the radiation safe levels and
a bunch of people that went to that
school started developing tumors and
[__] like that yeah and then Steven S
showed up and he snapped that guy's arm
and he [__] building building five G
Towers on elementary schools is the kind
of job description that is reserved for
a really comedic villain right like that
like an overthe toop silly like if I was
going to make like a comic book but it
make it funny I would be like all right
the bad guy what's he do for Lou he's a
billionaire is company builds 5G Towers
on elementary schools you'd go that's F
that's a funny bad guy thing but it's
really happening what if it's a black
superhero whose power is that he's
violent and he just fights everybody
right you think about based off
disrespect and he doesn't understand the
difference between private and public
property right what if it was something
like that uh by the way we have to get
to that at some point but I got to say
him him making the argument that Riley
showing up to his business and you know
what I mean it's illegal and it's all
this other [__] his entire comic is Isam
going to private businesses and beating
up people at their private businesses
that's [__] hilarious some pointed
that out on Twitter and I was howling
like isn't isom's whole superpower that
he goes to private businesses and kicks
the [__] out of the people who own the
businesses all right well uh is there
any update on this fgy or no uh yeah
actually the kids uh the kids at the
school made a statement I sent it to you
okay let's probably let's probably not
really okay oh yeah they guess they did
did you see the kids at the school made
a statement
merch oh
no I knew
this that's [__] up
fie
what honestly I would have went with the
the Shriner hospital that weird little
kid that looks like yeah he looks like
uh what's his name the old [__] a
little businessman he looks like a
little Humphrey
Bogart so what they just like got rid of
the commercial like actual there St Jude
copyrighting people on YouTube that
would be oh no this is from the official
Channel huh they just suck
[Music]